merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur depuis plus
d'une semaine Paris est devenu une ville
submergée par des montagnes de déchets
et oui mes chers collègues je ne vous
apprends rien je pense
cette mille tonnes de poubelles non
ramassées une recondition de la grève
qui est annoncée jusqu'au 20 mars alors
cette situation peut entraîner des
risques sanitaires conséquents bien sûr
aggravé par la recrudescence de la
présence des rats appelé les surmulots à
Paris dans les espaces publics de la
capitale monsieur le ministre les
Parisiens sont en colère pourtant la
mairie de Paris personne ne semble s'en
émouvoir madame Hidalgo a même annoncé
son soutien entier et total au mouvement
social
et oui c'est la vérité constatant cette
inertie la chef de file de l'opposition
à Paris madame Rachida Dati vous a saisi
hier vous avez donc chargé monsieur le
ministre le préfet de police de demander
à la mère de Paris de réquisitionner les
moyens en matériel et en personnel
nécessaire au ramassage des poubelles en
réponse ce matin le premier adjoint de
Madame Hidalgo affirme que c'est le
gouvernement qui a créé cette situation
quel déni quelle mauvaise volonté alors
Monsieur le Ministre quand l'État
va-t-il se substituer à la mairie de
Paris pour régler cette situation et
surtout dans quel délai
pour vous répondre
la parole d'un monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les outre-mer monsieur
Darmanin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice vous connaissez déjà
tout à la suite de 9 jours de grève et
chacun a pu constater qu'il soit
parisien d'occasion ou parisiens
d'habitude l'annoncellement dans
certains arrondissements de Paris d'un
certain nombre de poubelles que vous
avez qualifiez-vous de plusieurs
milliers de tonnes posent des questions
pour la sécurité évidemment de nos
concitoyens ou même d'ailleurs où il y a
des manifestations mais pose aussi des
questions de salubrité publique que
chacun peut constater et pour avoir été
comme beaucoup ici gestionnaire d'une
collectivité locale chacun peut voir ce
que c'est qu'attendre 9 jours et voir
des milliers de tonnes d'ordures et de
poubelles effectivement être sur la voie
publique j'ai donc demandé mais au nom
de la salubrité publique puisque mise à
l'intérieur est en charge d'un tutelle
sur le préfet de police et préfecture de
police et après avoir contacté
évidemment Madame la Maire de Paris
après avoir été saisi vous avez évoqué
Madame Dati en effet par plusieurs mères
d'arrondissement mais aussi par
plusieurs élus parisiens quelle que soit
leur bord politique après avoir été
saisi par eux j'ai donc demandé à Madame
Hidalgo d'abord évidemment à l'oral et
ensuite ce matin par la terminale
préfecture de police par écrit de
pouvoir faire ce que le droit lui permet
de faire notamment que la mairie de
Paris a fait pendant 10 de la loi
travail puisque il y a déjà eu
effectivement une situation similaire de
réquisitionner la question qui relève à
la fois du relèvement du des poubelles
qui sont relevées pardon de l'espace
public comme de l'incinération parce
qu'il s'agit bien des deux sujets à
l'oral j'ai entendu en effet ce matin le
premier adjoint évoqué le fait qu'il ne
serait pas favorable à cette situation
j'attends évidemment que Madame la Maire
de Paris réponde par écrit à la demande
par écrit du préfet de police et si ce
soir cette confirmation est effectuerite
Paris ne prenait pas ses responsabilités
je le dis ce soir demain matin au plus
tard le préfet de police propose
possèdera réquisition
au nom de la salubrité publique et je
crois que tous les parisiens quel que
soit ce qu'ils pensent de la réforme des
retraites en sont heureux
madame Dumas
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
de votre réponse c'est vrai qu'à chaque
grève Paris s'enfonce un peu plus dans
l'insalubrité dans laquelle Anne Hidalgo
et ses alliés ont plongé les Parisiens
nous sommes aujourd'hui à moins de 500
jours de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
l'image de notre pays et de sa capitale
est durablement dégradée auprès des
touristes et des observateurs étrangers
qui sont sidérés il est donc grand temps
d'agir merci